the Senate Democratic leader says there
should be no vote on the tax bill until
Democrat Doug Jones is seated in the
Senate Jones as you know defeated
Republican Roy Moore in Alabama's
special Senate election by about one and
a half percent of the vote on Tuesday
night but state officials are still
counting some of the ballots and more
refuses to concede Manuel Bojorquez is
in Birmingham with more as possible
options men well good morning good
morning unless doug jones final margin
of victory is within half a percentage
point the state will not launch an
automatic recount Roy Moore can request
one and pay for one himself after
Alabama declares Jones the winner and so
far more refuses to surrender we are
indeed in a struggle to preserve our
republic our civilization and our
religion and a set free of suffering
humanity and the battle rages on in a
nearly five-minute video statement
released overnight Republican Roy Moore
refused to concede Alabama's special
election after being defeated by
Democrat Doug Jones
it's his clean-cut is it's gonna get
Jones says senators from both parties
and even President Trump called to
congratulate him we talked about finding
that common ground to work together and
he invited me over to the White House to
visit as soon as I get up there
Alabama's Secretary of State Governor
and Attorney General together have until
January 3rd to certify the votes before
an automatic recount can be considered
this has been a very close race and we
were waiting certification by the
secretary of state steve flowers is
Alabama's leading political analyst Roy
Moore has said it's not over yet does he
really have a case for a recount under
Alabama law he really doesn't if he
wants a recount he's got to pay for it
which cost about a million dollars which
he probably doesn't have Jones says he's
leaving it to Moore to reach out to him
I would say do the right thing raw it's
time that we heal you know it's time
that we get together it's not the first
time Roy Moore has refused to admit
defeat as Chief Justice of Alabama
Supreme Court he refused to follow a
federal court order to remove a monument
to the ten commandments from the
courthouse and later he rejected the
Supreme Court's decision legalizing
same-sex marriage he was
removed from office both times John
Manuel Thanks